hier sehen sie schon hier einen
vorausblick vielen dank an die regie
annalena baerbock die
außenministerin und das ist nämlich das
nächste ressort was hier aufgerufen wird
ja nach china menschenrechte der ampel
koalitionsvertrag hat in einigen
außenpolitischen punkten einen neuen
zungenschlag das ist auch durchaus schon
deutlich geworden bei den antritt
besuchen von annalena baerbock
die sie schon absolviert hat im letzten
jahr schon im dezember direkt nach
amtsantritt paris brüssel warschau sie
war viel unterwegs in den ersten 35
tagen letzte woche der antrag besuch in
washington am montag der antrittsbesuch
eine gute stunde lang ein werden jetzt
die abgeordneten über also die aus
politischen pläne der ampel beraten im
koalitionsvertrag auf immerhin 28 seiten
festgehalten und der themenbereich hier
wird eröffnet von der bundesministerin
von annalena baerbock
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen erst mal in
allen ein schönes und vor allem
friedliches neues jahr auch wenn es
außenpolitisch leider sehr eisig
gestartet ist seit wochen lässt russland
an der grenze zur ukraine truppen
aufmarschieren auf diese provokation
haben wir als bundesregierung gemeinsam
mit unseren partnerinnen und partnern
deutlich reagiert die souveränität der
ukraine und die unverrückbar kite der
grenzen in europa sind für uns nicht
verhandelbar
eine neue militärische aggression gegen
die ukraine trägt für russland ein hohes
preisschild und vielleicht gilt trotz
dieser unglaublich besorgniserregenden
russischen agieren gibt es nur eine
lösung und die heißt diplomatie um die
aktuellen spannungen zu lösen es ist
daher wichtig und richtig dass diese
woche in verschiedenen foren gespräche
geführt werden im strategischen dialog
zwischen den usa und russland im nato
russland rat in der osze und von
frankreich und deutschland da arbeiten
wir eng zusammen um neue verhandlungen
im normandie format wieder aufzunehmen
denn klar ist es gibt keine entscheidung
über die sicherheit in europa ohne
europa
liebe kollegen legen die aktuelle
situation spiegelt die welt in der
europäische außenpolitik sich neu
bewähren muss eine welt mit wachsenden
geopolitischen spannungen in der es zwar
zum glück keine block konfrontation mehr
gibt aber ein wettbewerb zwischen
autoritären kräften und liberalen
demokratien eine welt in der uns
wirtschaft und technologie immer enger
vernetzen aber eben nicht automatisch
zur stärkung von demokratie und vor
allen dingen nicht automatisch zur
stärkung von menschenrechten geführt
haben und in einer welt in der wir
zugleich all die globalen
herausforderungen nur gemeinsam angehen
können und ich bin davon überzeugt dass
wir in einer solchen welt auf grundlage
einer klaren wertevorstellung die
interessen deutschlands und europas in
der welt vertreten und ja ich
unterstreiche ich hier noch einmal sehr
deutlich werte und interessen sind keine
gegensätze sondern zwei seiten derselben
medaille
wenn wir anderen akteuren ermöglichen
sich auf unserem eigenen europäischen
binnenmarkt nicht an regeln und
standards halten zu müssen hat die
europäische wirtschaft einen schweren
wettbewerbsnachteil
und daher gilt für mich heute umso mehr
diplomatie ist ein zentraler pfeiler von
außenpolitik aber es geht eben auch um
praktisches und vor allen dingen
kohärentes handeln auf allen
politikfeldern von handel über
gesundheit bis zu einer gemeinsamen
weltweiten und internationalen
sozialpolitik und deshalb ist der
grundsatz dieser ampelkoalition eine
vorher rente außenpolitik in der
einzelne politikfelder und vor allen
dingen die unterschiedlichen ministerien
nicht gegeneinander sondern miteinander
arbeiten weil wir nur so den grossen low
großen globalen herausforderungen
gerecht werden können
was das konkret bedeutet will ich nicht
weniger siemens hier kurz beschreiben
weil sie den auftrag das handeln auch
meines hauses prägen auch wenn ich die
meiste zeit der letzten vier wochen
natürlich vor allen dingen mit den
aktuellen krisen und das sind nicht
wenige verbracht haben zuallererst gilt
deutschland kann im herzen europas nicht
ohne die gemeinsame europäische union
unsere union müssen wir gemeinsam nach
innen stärken damit sie nach außen
glaubhaft und vor allen dingen
presidente auftreten kann als starke
wirtschaftsnationen in europa und vor
allen dingen als gemeinsame europäische
werte union muss unser anspruch als
europäerinnen und europäer sein und das
wird auch das leitmotiv unser deutschen
g7 präsidentschaft seien deutlich zu
machen wofür wir stehen und nicht nur
wogegen wir sind wir stehen als
europäerinnen und europäer für eine
regelbasierte
internationale ordnung und vor allen
dingen stehen wir für ein
vorausschauendes
präventives kann denn ja
wir wissen der ist nur glory insolvenzen
aber je später wir handeln desto teurer
wird es das wird nirgendwo
offensichtlicher als in der klimakrise
jedes zehntel grad weniger an
erderwärmung ist ein beitrag zur
menschlichen sicherheit
extreme hitze trockenheit oder steigende
meeresspiegel können regionen
unbewohnbar machen indonesien plant
deshalb bereits den umzug seiner
hauptstadt und deswegen machen wir als
neue regierung klima außenpolitik jetzt
zur priorität
das auswärtige amt nur deutschland nicht
den internationalen klima haster
handlung entscheidend mitprägen und
führen sondern gemeinsam und das ist
unser kohärenter ansatz in dieser neuen
bundesregierung gemeinsam als
auswärtiges amt mit dem wirtschafts und
klimaministerium mit dem ministerium für
internationale zusammenarbeit mit dem
ministerium für umwelt und
verbraucherschutz werden wir verstärkt
klima und energie partnerschaften
ausbauen und wg die
sicherheitspolitische frage unserer zeit
den klimaschutz gemeinsam mit unseren
partnern in der welt an und zwar auch
hier präventiv denn das gute und das ist
ja die riesengroße chance die wir haben
in einer vernetzten welt ist dass wir
dank neuer technologien bereits 20
prozent der katastrophen eigentlich
vorher sehen könnten wenn wir gemeinsam
zusammenarbeiten wenn wir gemeinsam
unsere instrumente nutzen wetter
vorsagen erlauben es uns heute zum
beispiel schon tage bevor ein zyklon auf
eine küste trifft menschen aber eben
auch hab und gut zu evakuieren
präventive humanitäre hilfe kann
notlagen verhindern und abschwächen und
ressourcen sparen und das müssen wir
gemeinsam nutzen
uns ist es daher ein zentrales anliegen
dieses prinzip des vorausschauenden
multilateralismus im rahmen der g7
weiter auszubauen und auch darüber
hinaus gemeinsam strategisch zu
investieren denn milliarden
investitionen von anderen in
technologien innerhalb europas aber auch
außerhalb europas sei es in halbleiter
sei es in medizintechnik oder auch in
große energieprojekte das sind nicht
immer automatisch nur wohltätigkeiten
sondern sie folgen auch am
geostrategischen kalkül und wir haben
das auf deutliche art und weise bei der
globalen impfstoff verteilung gesehen
und ich sage klar und deutlich wir
müssen hier auch als europäerinnen und
europäer besser werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
als neue bundesregierung zudem eigene
durch eine selbstverständlichkeit im
koalitionsvertrag formuliert nämlich
eine politik auf höhe der
gesellschaftlichen realität zu machen
und das gilt auch in der außenpolitik
daher folgen wir dem beispiel kanadas
und schwedens und setzten eine strategie
für eine feministische außenpolitik auf
und ich ja ich weiss manchen fällt es
schwer den begriff auszusprechen aber
eigentlich ist es ganz simpel es geht um
repräsentanz es geht um rechte und es
geht um ressourcen
denn wenn die hälfte der bevölkerung
nicht gleichberechtigt beteiligt wer
präsentiert oder auch bezahlt ist sind
demokratien nicht vollkommen und zum
anderen erleben geweiht weit dass der
abbau von rechten von mädchen und frauen
auch ein gradmesser für das erstarken
von autoritären kräften ist und das gilt
in ganz besonderer und furchtbarste art
und weise für afghanistan und deswegen
war eine meiner ersten maßnahmen ein
aktionsplan für afghanistan aufzulegen
wir leben dieser die tage eine absolute
humanitäre katastrophe deswegen müssen
wir alles dafür tun die humanitäre hilfe
zu verstärken ja wir müssen auch das
haben wir gemeinsam hier mit vielen
vielen angeregt und als koalition
beschlossen die evakuierung afghanistans
und den bundeswehreinsatz aufarbeiten
und evaluieren aber ich sage ganz klar
und deutlich an dieser stelle die
innenministerin und ich als
aussenministerin arbeiten vor allen
dingen mit hochdruck daran ein neues
humanitäres aufnahmeprogramm auf dem weg
zu bringen um jetzt dazu für sorgen die
besonders schutzbedürftigen zusätzlich
und das sind frauen und wie aus
afghanistan heraus zu bringen das sind
dicke bretter das braucht zusammenarbeit
dafür reichlich eine bundesregierung
sondern es braucht die zusammenarbeit
hier in diesem hohen hause mit ihn als
opposition mit ihnen als sehr geehrter
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages
ich freue mich auf diese zusammenarbeit
und danke ihnen für die gemeinsame
arbeit in den nächsten jahren herzlichen
dank
diese dicken außenpolitischen dritter
die zusammenarbeit so stößt hier an der
lena der burg ihren auftritt hier zu
ihrem syrien auftakt zu ihrem ressort
das jahr sei außenpolitisch ein sieg
gestartet so hat sie begonnen und das
kann man wohl sagen der russische
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine hat die nato und den westen in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt darum laufen
ja in dieser woche bemühungen auf
hochtouren in verschiedenen liebe
kollegen
mit ihnen gemeinsam hier zu debattieren
zunächst ein glückwunsch zu den antritt
besuchen in paris brüssel auch warschau
das war sehr wichtig zu den besuch in
washington
und anderen internationalen gremien sie
haben den richtigen ton getroffen sie
haben sich klar für eine enge und
verlässliche
transatlantische partnerschaft
ausgesprochen sich zur verantwortung
deutschlands in der nato bekannt und in
europa die ersten wichtigen zeichen
gesetzt auch der koalitionsvertrag das
habe ich an anderer stelle bereits
gesagt ist von einem erfreulichen maß an
realismus und pragmatismus
jedenfalls and worten geprägt in diesem
sinne als ministerin biete ich ihnen
ausdrücklich die zusammenarbeit mit der
cdu csu fraktion an ich glaube es
wichtig dass sie demokratische mitte
dieses hauses in den wichtigen
europäischen und internationalen
vorhaben und herausforderungen zusammen
arbeitet die cdu csu ist dazu bereit
gleichwohl zeigt sich das wahre ambition
niveau und die konkrete politik im
handel
supress sup utting ist in st
der koalitionsvertrag ist in diesem
sinne viel versprechend im wahrsten
sinne des wortes und es zeigen sich auch
erste bruchlinien in der ampelkoalition
vielstimmigkeit ist aber genau das was
wir jetzt nicht brauchen haben selber
von kohärenz und von realitätssinn
gesprochen deswegen zu einigen punkten
unsere anmerkungen stichwort russland da
versteigt sich der generalsekretär der
größten regierungsfraktion zu der
aussage im verhältnis zwischen russland
und der ukraine werde ein
internationaler konflikt
herbeigeredet meine meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren dieser internationale
konflikt ist durch einen immensen
truppenaufmarsch an der grenze der
ukraine von putin herbei befohlen und
nicht von uns herbei geredet worden
derselbe putin der schon die creme
annektiert hat der die souveränität der
ukraine im osten ständig verletzt das
war bisher die einhellige meinung in
europa was ist dazu die meinung der
ampelkoalition was ist die
außenpolitische position
waffenlieferungen aller harbeck oder
geschichtsklitterung aller kühn hat dazu
er warnt erwarten wir ihre antworten
stichwort china sie haben sich zur
menschenrechtslage auch in xingjiang
klar geäußert dass auch problematisiert
hier erwarten wir eine kohärente
position der gesamten bundesregierung es
ist nicht damit getan dass zwei
ministerinnen so lobenswert das ende im
ergebnis ist sagen dass sie nicht zu den
olympischen spielen zu fahren nur
wahrlich europäisch ist wenn man das auf
europäischer ebene abstimmt und das
gemeinsam mit dem partner ländern in
europa macht und nicht eine singuläre
teile entscheidung eines teil kabinetts
trifft also da können sie deutlich
besser werden die wir kolleginnen und
kollegen stichwort europa sie haben sich
größtes vorgenommen die vereinigten
staaten von europa kleiner geht es nicht
um dann gleich beim thema taxonomie
einen
nationalstaatlichen kurs zu fahren liebe
appell koalitionäre auch an der stelle
müssen sie besser werden ja das tut
ihnen weh liebe grüne aber das ist
nationalstaatlich gedacht das ist nicht
europäisch tat nicht gedacht da müssen
sie schon zur kenntnis nehmen dass sie
klare mehrheit in europa das anders sind
und um die eu in ihrer
handlungsfähigkeit steht es schlecht die
wichtigsten verhandlungen über die
zukunft der eu über europa werden
derzeit in genf geführt von russen und
amerikanern europäer sitzen noch nicht
mal am katzentisch was tun sie denn dass
wir dabei sind was sind denn ihre
vorschläge dass wir dabei sind selbst 35
ein grüner hat dazu vorschläge gemacht
was man alles von russland an der stelle
erwarten könnte film wieder freigeben
die ukraine in ruhe lassen aufhören mit
mordanschlägen auf oppositionelle aus
russland und so weiter und so fort an
der stelle denke ich oft an bruno
moravetz der immer gefragt hat wo es
jochen behle ich frage mich wo ist olaf
scholz wann fängt er endlich an auch
außenpolitisch wann fängt diese
bundesregierung endlich an auch
außenpolitisch hier wieder europa
voranzutreiben natürlich gemeinsam mit
frankreich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und diplomatie ist wichtig das haben sie
gesagt aber wolfgang ischinger hat
darauf hingewiesen dass wir an der
richtigen stelle auch militärische
fähigkeiten brauchen wie steht es darum
da setzten sie einen besonderen akzent
im koalitionsvertrag wir sollen den
beobachterstatus beim atomwaffen
verbotsantrag haben ja das ist ihre
große forderung gewesen nur liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen niemand findet
atomwaffen gut nur sie tragen zu unserer
sicherheit bei ihren europa und sie
begeben sich auf eine moralische bessere
position und amerikaner und briten und
franzosen können solange die schmuddel
arbeit meint machen nein so ist es nicht
ich komme zum schluss das sind unsere
partner und wer wahrlich europäisch
denkt und im bündnis denkt der stellt
unsere bündnispartner nicht ein
schlechtes licht sondern leistete an
einem eigenen verteidigungs beitrag und
würdigt was andere für unseren frieden
und unsere freiheit leisten herzlichen
dank vielen dank herr
kollege banner johann wadephul bales für
die cdu/csu-fraktion stellvertreter
fraktionsvorsitzender und von ihnen gab
es erst mal ein lob zum eingang in
richtung der bundesministerin in
richtung annalena baerbock
ohne wie das hier weiter geht ihnen der
debatte werden als nächste hat das wort
hier mit schmied für die spd-fraktion
der außenpolitischen sprecher
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren mein persönliches
highlight in den koalitionsverhandlungen
war der moment als wir über
friedenspolitik geredet haben da kam
ganz spontan von den grünen ja klar
kennen wir und auch aus den reihen der
fdp hieß es hat das haben wir doch schon
immer so gemacht erinnerungen an die
sozial liberale koalition
entspannungs politik bemühen um
ausgleich und frieden in europa
bemühungen um abrüstung und auch bei
fragen von krieg und frieden haben die
drei parteien
der ampel in der deutschen geschichte
wichtige wegmarken gesetzt das nein von
rot grün unter schröder zum irakkrieg
und er maßgeblich auf herrn westerwelle
zurückführen zurückzuführende
die enthaltung der damaligen regierung
bei der libyen intervention das zeigt an
die basis die gemeinsame basis dieser
regierungskoalition ist der einsatz für
frieden
ist bewahrung förderung wenn notwendig
auch wiederherstellung von frieden und
das auf grundlage der festen verankerung
im atlantischen bündnis und der eu
und es geht uns in der tat wo auch um
konkrete fortschritte bei der abrüstung
deshalb habe ich auch gar nichts dagegen
hat auch diese bundesregierung gar
nichts dagegen dass usa und russland
endlich wieder ein dialog über
strategische stabilität führen über die
wieder inkraftsetzung von
rüstungskontroll verträgen oder über die
erweiterung von atomen
begrenzungen von atomarer rüstung sei es
den vertrag in europa ist dies die
strategischen atomwaffen und es ist gut
dass diese regierung sich auf nach den
atomwaffen verbots vertrag politisch zu
begleiten über das annehmen eines
beobachterstatus und mir sagen wir waren
von der widerstand den sie teils aus den
reihen der union gegenüber diesen
schritt formuliert haben er erinnert
mich an die auseinandersetzung vor etwa
50 jahren als es darum ging ob die
bundesrepublik deutschland den hatten
dem nichtweiterverbreitungsvertrages
soll ende der 60er jahre weil das war
damals
war es war es war damals auch die frage
könnt kriegen wir das hin wieder cdu csu
und die cdu csu hat blockiert die
regierung brandt hat es dann hin
bekommen eben auch ohne die partner vor
den kopf zu stoßen und genau das gleiche
wollen wir auch beim atomwaffen verbots
vertrag über den beobachterstatus und
verwandlung von atomwaffen großen der
welt voranzutreiben und schließlich
wollen wir uns auch selber in die
pflicht nehmen über die erarbeitung
eines rüstungsexport kontrollgesetz wo
wir endlich auf gesetzlicher grundlage
eine restriktive waffenexport politik in
deutschland durchsetzen wollen sie haben
vollkommen recht die ministerin hat
angesprochen der kollege wadephul auch
der frieden in europa ist bedroht er ist
bedroht durch die aggression von
russland aktuell auch durch den
truppenaufmarsch russlands an der
ukraine
und es ist richtig dass sowohl aus der
bundesregierung wie aus den reihen der
koalitionsfraktionen
darauf hingewirkt wird dass wir jetzt
diplomatie und der eskalation betreiben
im format um die konkreten fortschritte
beim waffenstillstand bei der
entflechtung der streitkräfte im künftig
gebiet voran zu bringen bei der osze um
die mission der osze zu
unterstützen und weitergehende schritte
zur frage der stationierung
konventionelle streitkräfte in europa
hin zu bekommen genauso klar ist und
auch das hat oder scholz in der
regierungserklärung habe ton eine
aggression russlands wird sanktionen
nach sich ziehen alle optionen liegen
auf dem tisch verschiedenen sanktionen
persönliche
sektorale sanktionen die auch den
energiesektor betroffen könnten
betreffen können alles ist mit den
europäern und unseren partner in den usa
in den usa abgestimmt und genau in
diesem sinne können wir durch
geschlossenheit dann auch die russische
aggression zurückdrehen und hoffentlich
denn das muss das ziel sein das
waffenstillstandsabkommen von linz auch
endlich umsetzen das ist unsere linie
und die werden wir mit großer
geschlossenheit und vorantreiben
olaf scholz hat im wahlkampf
festgehalten die europäische union ist
unser wichtigstes nationales interesse
und deshalb haben wir uns sehr viel
vorgenommen zur stärkung der
europäischen souveränität zusammen vor
allem mit dem wichtigsten partner
innerhalb der eu mit frankreich
souveränität heißt handlungsfähigkeit
europas nach innen wie nach außen da
geht es um diplomatie es geht auch um
militärische fähigkeiten auch vor allem
geht es auch darum kraftvoll in
innovation in neue technologien in
zukunftsfähige arbeitsplätze zu
investieren neue technologien in europa
zu beheimaten
handelspolitik fair und gerecht zu
gestalten
die währungspolitik finanzen die
internationale finanzpolitik mit einem
starken euro zu gestalten diese
europäische souveränität ist die
voraussetzung dafür dass in den viel
beschworenen systemwettbewerb zwischen
demokratie und autoritären systemen die
europäer die demokratien die oberhand
behalten können es geht darum dass wir
konkret unseren bürgerinnen und bürgern
und auch der welt beweisen dass eine
demokratie in der lage ist prosperität
gleichheit und gerechtigkeit und auch
innovation zu leisten dass wir
vielleicht sogar besser hinbekommen als
autoritäre systeme der systemwettbewerb
wird nicht über die anzahl der raketen
gewonnen er wird gewonnen über die
leistungsfähigkeit unserer gesellschaft
und unserer wirtschaft im
internationalen vergleich und daran
können wir nur vorankommen und gewinnen
wenn die europäische union geschlossen
diese europäische souveränität aus boden
und deshalb ist es stark auf china zwar
richtig denn das ist eine
herausforderung aber die frage richtet
sich immer an uns selbst kriegen wir das
selber in kriegen wie es als
demokratisch verfasste gesellschaften
hin dass wir auch in zukunft einen hohen
lebensstandard und auch eine gerechte
gesellschaft organisiert bekommen und
deshalb ist mit blick auf china diese
europäische realität so wichtig wie die
europäische in der pacific strategie wie
die konkreten schritte die wir vor ort
eingehen wollen ich will zum schluss mit
blick auf china eines sagen was ich mit
großer sorge betrachtet das ist hier der
aufrüstung der rüstungswettlauf in der
region selbst asien und ich glaube bei
allem bei aller notwendigkeit robust
dagegen zu halten wird es entscheidend
darauf ankommen den gedanken der
kollektiven sicherheit auch stärker nach
ostasien zu bringen das gehört für mich
zu einer klugen indopazifik strategie
dazu herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
für die spd fraktion ist er der
außenpolitische sprecher
sieht eine gemeinsame basis der
bundesregierung vor allem im streben im
gemeinsamen einsatz für frieden das als
klammer in diesen außenpolitischen
bereich außen europa und menschenrechte
das fehlt hier runter und annalena
baerbock hatte ja auch betont dass die
internationale klimapolitik die vom
bundesumweltministerium sind auswärtige
amt gewandert ist eine größere rolle
spielen wird nächster redner hier peter
bistro für die fdp
noch haben wir keinen krieg vom zaun
gebrochen das hat ein grüner kollege zu
mir gesagt auf die frage wie ist das
jetzt so nach 20 jahren wieder an der
regierung zu sein ja in der tat es war
der grüne außenminister fischer der
deutsche soldaten in den ersten
kriegseinsatz 45 damals geschickt hat
den 90er jahren und dabei sind die
grünen damals in den bundestag
reingekommen auf dem ticket der
friedensbewegung das zeigt dass die
grünen damals wie heute
innenpolitische heuchler und
außenpolitische kriegs 3
weiters die heuchelei und die
kriegstreiberei bestätigen auch schon
die ersten ausführungen die öffentliche
mit ausführung von ministerin werbung
schauen sie mal sie haben angebliche
sorgen um die einhaltung der
menschenrechte das sind keine zwei tagen
da haben sie gesagt in kasachstan wurde
internet und die sozialen medien
eingeschränkt dabei sind hier in
deutschland freie medien werden zensiert
die arbeit von freien journalisten wird
behindert kanäle freie medien werden
abgeschaltet und der opposition denn
sogar gelöscht ausländischen
fernsehsendern wird keine sendelizenz
erteilt und neueste nachricht telegramm
soll abgeschaltet werden nur über sich
die opposition darin verabredet dazu
kein wort menschenrechte spielen da
keine rolle aber wenn in kasachstan für
zwei stunden das internet abgeschaltet
wird dann werden menschenrechte dann
sind sie hin gefahr ja wer soll ihnen
das abkaufen bitteschön
genauso einschränkungen der
versammlungsfreiheit in kasachstan aber
das hier in deutschland jeden tag zig
tausende menschen gegen ihre regierung
demonstrieren wollen und deren
versammlungsfreiheit behinderte dazu
kein wort von innen
und liebe kollegen von der fdp gerade
sie graf lambsdorff und von der spd ich
muss sie fragen wie konnten sie das
zulassen wirklich deutsche außenpolitik
war immer der nachkriegszeit war immer
von großen staatsmännern geprägt und es
war nach den zwei verlorenen kriegen
eine außenpolitik die auf frieden
ausgelegt war er angefangen mit
stresemann des 26 die wiederaufnahme der
völker punkt bewirkt hat gekrönt durch
hans dietrich genscher wiedervereinigung
dazwischen walter scheel aufnahme in die
vereinten nationen und willy brandt
versöhnung mit dem osten frieden mit der
sowjetunion trotz der gräuel des zweiten
weltkrieges ja und diese politik wurde
auch honoriert deutschland wurde in die
weltgemeinschaft wieder aufgenommen und
die beiden politiker stresemann und dran
haben den friedensnobelpreis
bekommen und auf der anderen seite haben
sie die tradition der grünen eben mit
dem ersten kriegseinsatz seit 45 und
herr schmid das ist eine
geschichtsklitterung was sie hier gerade
betrieben haben indem sie versuchen die
grünen einzugemeinden und zu ihnen die
in die liberal soziale außenpolitische
tradition also was sind was sind die
ersten
was waren die ersten eckpunkte folgen
vom der aussenministerin werbung das
größte land der welt russland sofort
konfrontation wichtigstes
deutsch-russisches projekt nord stream 2
verhindern
70 prozent des energiebedarfs müssen wir
importieren russland ist mit abstand der
wichtigste lieferant und zitieren in die
konfrontation in diesem land das geht so
nicht
genauso china
bevölkerungsreichstes land der welt sie
legen sich gleich mit china an
kritisieren das land wegen der uiguren
wollen die olympischen spiele
boykottieren
welche übrig welche hybris vw ohne china
nicht vorstellbar schreibt das manager
magazin
vier von zehn deutschen autos gehen in
den export nach china
wessen interessen vertreten sie
vertreten sie frau berbalk die der
deutschen bevölkerung und der deutschen
industrie sind das nicht können sie die
konnte meine zeit ist sonder deswegen
die letzten zwei sätze ich mich
eingelassen sich der
doktor wagen polen sie haben vorhin den
kanzler in die pflicht genommen und ich
finde da haben sie recht der
bundeskanzler muss sich jetzt
entscheiden in wessen tradition die
deutsche außenpolitik gehen soll der
großen versöhner und diplomaten
schilderten sie reden nur über sein
engagement in brand oder konnte sich
rasend schlägers steinewerfer und
kriegsfall was fischer das ist hier die
frage dankeschön
[Applaus]
peter bis dahin war dass der
außenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
hätten sie bitte die maske auch für
abgeordnete wir müssen sie auch wirklich
hart überzogen wir müssen gleich mal
sehen
wie wir damit umgehen
als nächstes in dieser debatte erhält
das wort der abgeordnete alexander graf
lambsdorff für die fdp-fraktion
erster stellvertreter
fraktionsvorsitzender der liberalen
vielen dank frau präsidentin das ist ein
bisschen ein komischer ort zwischen der
afg und gregor gysi zu reden das ist wie
zwischen den chefredakteuren von russia
today und der komsomolskaja prawda es
ist eine etwas originelle situation
deswegen wollen wir mal starten damit zu
sagen dass gute politik mit dem
betrachten der realität beginnt an der
grenze zur ukraine zieht die russische
regierung 100.000 soldaten schweres
gerät und luftfahrzeuge zusammen in genf
treffen sich russland und die usa zu
gesprächen es geht um
sicherheitsgarantien truppenbewegungen
es geht um kurz und
mittelstreckenraketen kurz es geht um
europas sicherheit in kasachstan ist ein
autoritärer herrscher auf demonstranten
schießen den belarus bis braucht ein
diktator zynisch die lebensträume
zahlreicher menschen für einen angriff
auf die europäische union und in mali
unterstützen wagner sollten und jetzt
auch russische soldaten die
militärregierung während diese wahlen
auf den sankt nimmerleins tag verschiebt
das ist alles sehr real wer also in
diesen tagen die realität betrachtet und
genug erfahrung mitbringt fühlt sich an
die jahre des kalten krieges erinnert
globale spannungen teilweise harte
systemen rivalität
stellvertreter konflikt aber
glücklicherweise keine große
militärische auseinandersetzung kein
heißer krieg dabei ist die
internationale lage heute sogar
unübersichtlicher als zu zeiten der
block konfrontation die weltgemeinschaft
unsere gesellschaften und
volkswirtschaften sind vernetzter als in
den 70er und 80er jahren aber gerade
deshalb auch verwundbare das macht die
lage eher noch schwieriger zu alten und
bekannten gefahren treten neue risiken
wie hybride kriegsführung überschall
waffen und terrorismus auch der
klimawandel hat eine
sicherheitspolitische dimension der
aufstieg chinas fordert die
freiheitlichen demokratien heraus
gleichzeitig geraten die werte der
aufklärung freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaat weltweit unter druck auch
hier bei uns in euro wir erleben also
nicht
einfach eine wiederholung bekannter
historischer prozesse frau werburg hat
es gesagt gehen nicht den neuen neuen
kalten krieg nicht ein großkonflikt wird
prägend seien in den nächsten jahren
sondern mehrere bekannte strukturen der
weltordnung zerfallen dabei gültige
normen werden missachtet das recht des
stärkeren tritt immer häufiger an die
stelle der stärke des rechts und dieser
wandel meine damen und herren fordert
deutschland massiv heraus wir müssen
außenpolitik neu denken teilweise auch
in kategorien die uns gesellschaftlich
mitunter schwer fallen die geopolitik
abschreckung resilienz die zielsetzung
dieser koalition ist klar wir wollen
eine werteorientierte außenpolitik aber
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag auch für
die schwierigen fragen wichtige
weichenstellungen vorgenommen und jahren
wartet auch in den nuklearen fragen ist
der koalitionsvertrag eindeutig und
bündnistreue wir haben in der letzten
debatte bereits herausgearbeitet damit
im herbst
werden wir eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie vorlegen eine
gesamtstrategie die unsere werte und
interessen unsere ziele und prioritäten
ausbuchstabiert und transparent macht
das wird die bundesregierung fordern
aber auch uns hier im deutschen
bundestag den dem parlament kommt in
diesem prozess eine wichtige rolle zu
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen kernbegriffe des
koalitionsvertrags den strategische
souveränität und strategische
solidarität mit blick auf die gespräche
in genf scherzte politiker diese woche
die verhandlungen zwischen den usa und
russland das sei die ware konferenz zur
zukunft europas eine konferenz ohne eu
entscheidet über wichtigste
weichenstellungen in europa die
wirkliche europäische zukunftskonferenz
von eu und mitgliedstaaten wird mit
diesem wortspiel abgewertet das werden
wir nicht zulassen das kann ich ihnen
versichern und auch hier an die
kolleginnen und kollegen von cdu und csu
der europapolitische ehrgeiz der ampel
ist definitiv größer als der der groko
wir haben keine angst vor mehr europa im
gegenteil die ereignisse dieser woche
zeigen doch dem letzte wie wichtig ist
es die europäische souveränität
strategisch zu stärken wir wollen und
müssen weniger abhängig weniger
verwundbar werden in der äußeren
sicherheit aber auch bei
energieversorgung rohstoffimporten und
digitaler technologie meine damen und
herren die koalition hat sich auch das
ziel gesetzt das transatlantische
bündnis zu erneuern wir wollen mehr
westen wagen wir unterstützt initiativen
wie die erlernte demokratien wir wären
die beziehungen zu unseren
freiheitlichen werte partnern weltweit
ausbauen und vertiefen gerade haben sie
bis zum schluss herr abgeordneter ja
wohl gerade im systemwettbewerb mit
autoritär regierten staaten wollen wir
solidarität mit unseren demokratischen
partnern üben das heißt für uns zum
beispiel staaten wie australien sie
bitte zum schluss herr abgeordneter
will merkt das aber nicht so richtig das
muss ein schlusssatz werden ja wohl also
für uns heißt strategische solidarität
unseren partnern weltweit beizustehen
wenn sie von ländern wie china unter
druck gesetzt werden oder ganz konkret
und jetzt im moment die ukraine wenn das
von russland aus geht viel da
ja alle punkte aus dem koalitionsvertrag
in sachen ausnahme von menschenrechten
ist kaum in einer rede bei einer solchen
aussprache zu schaffen auch nicht für
alexander graf lambsdorff der hier
sprach als stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender und gerne noch ein
bisschen länger gesprochen hätte aber
der bundestag ist mit seinem zeitplan
ein bisschen hinterher die debatte die
betreute schon gesagt sollen sich uhr
gehen und fliehen muss dann eine lösung
als bundestagsvizepräsidentin auch ein
bisschen auf den zeitpunkt achten gregor
gysi wird jetzt der nächste sein für die
linksfraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
sie frau außenministerin haben doch eine
werte basierte und deutlich hörbare
außenpolitik gekündigt angekündigt dazu
habe ich eine frage
julian assange sitzt derzeit mehr als
1000 tagen in isolationshaft in
großbritannien im wahlkampf waren sie
deutlich hörbar dafür die auslieferung
zu verhindern und seine freilassung zu
erreichen denn er deckte
kriegsverbrechen in den usa auf aber
nicht die kriegsverbrecher sollen zur
verantwortung gezogen werden sondern er
soll in den usa verurteilt werden so gab
es das erste urteil das die auslieferung
ablehnte als die ministerin wurden kann
das zweite urteil das die auslieferung
anordnete sie haben nichts dazu gesagt
sehen sie das führt dazu dass
politikerinnen und politiker immer
unglaubwürdiger werden sie hatten vor
dem ministeramt eine meinung vielleicht
haben sie jetzt noch aber sie äußern sie
nicht mehr und genau das geht nicht wenn
man eine werte basierte außenpolitik
und ich bin auch sehr gute beziehung zu
den usa und großbritannien aber
duckmäuser tun hilft dabei nicht weiter
im koalitionsvertrag steht
dass das ziel ist bewaffnete drohnen für
die bundeswehr zu bekommen also ich kann
davor nur warnen die us der us drohnen
krieg forderte tausende zivile opfer wie
die new york times jetzt enthüllt hat
glauben sie eine sekunde daran mit
bewaffneten drohnen rechtsstaatlichkeit
und menschenrechte durchsetzen zu können
es ist eine reine angriffs mache und das
steht im widerspruch zum
verteidigungsauftrag des grundgesetzes
so jetzt komme ich zu russland auf uns
stört der aufmarsch der soldaten der
massive aufmarsch der soldaten an der
grenze zur ukraine
aber wir dürfen 1 nie vergessen graf
lambsdorff nicht deutschland nicht die
sowjetunion hat deutschland im zweiten
weltkrieg überfallen sondern deutschland
hat die sowjetunion im zweiten weltkrieg
überfallen das kostete dieses land 27
millionen opfer
1962 gab es eine krise und bei dieser
kuba-krise bar vereinbart wurden
zwischen der sowjetunion und kuba das
sowjetische raketen unter sowjetischer
kontrolle auf kuba aufgestellt werden
und als die schiffe unterwegs waren rief
kennedy chruschtschow an und sagte das
kann er nicht zulassen er muss die
schiffe beschießen und dann gebe es
einen dritten weltkrieg weil das die
sicherheit der usa gefährde daraufhin
hat glücklicherweise rohstoff die
schiffe umdrehen lassen dafür haben die
usa raketen aus der türkei abgezogen
auch heute wäre das so stellen sie sich
doch mal vor drei souveräne staaten
russland mexiko und kuba vereinbarten
das russische soldaten auf kuba und
mexiko mit russischen waffen stationiert
werden niemals würden die usa das
hinnehmen und die nato auch nicht warum
billigten und billigen sie den usa ein
sicherheitsabstand zu aber russland
nicht das ist nicht nachvollziehbar was
die ukraine betrifft was sie bei ihnen
betrifft russland verletzt - zwei aber
die ukraine auch baum der den sie immer
nur das eine und das andere
und noch was es gab eine aktion in der
nato dass kein staat aufgenommen wird
der in einem territorialkonflikt ist und
die ukraine ist in einem kontext
territorialkonflikt das kann ganz
schnell zum bündnisfall für die
europäische union ist aber etwas anderes
damit kann man auch ihre sicherheit
erhöhen putin ist heute zweifellos
negativer als früher aber
2001 hat er hier im bundestag gesprochen
und die zusammenarbeit auf allen
gebieten angeboten und der westen war zu
arrogant darauf einzugehen das ist der
punkt
der panzer friedenspolitik das finde ich
völlig richtig aber frau außenministerin
dann muss endlich und sofort die
bundeswehr aus mali abgezogen werden wir
haben die offiziere ausgebildet die dort
putsche begehen die westafrikanische
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft ecowas schließt
die grenzen zumal zieht ihre botschafter
ab und wir bilden weiter aus das geht
einfach nicht und setzen wir brauchen
eine gute beziehung zu den usa zu
russland und zu china dazu muss man ein
vertrauen herstellen und sie machen und
wir haben zu allen drei staaten keine
guten beziehung und das geht nicht wir
brauchen diesbezüglich so wie es beiden
gesagt hat entweder endlich wieder das
völkerrecht und die diplomatie
sagte gregor gysi der im auswärtigen
ausschuss sitzt für die linksfraktionen
und es gab ein wechsel im
bundestagspräsidium
bundestagsvize präsidentin das hat jetzt
die sitzungsleitung
[Applaus]
90/grüne aus gesprächen
wissen dass russland nicht die
sowjetunion ist die sowjetunion hat die
schlussakte von helsinki unterschrieben
die sowjetunion der damalige
generalsekretär gorbatschow hat selber
den grundsatz dass jedes land frei ist
sein bündnis zu wählen unterschrieben
und da lobe ich mir die sowjetunion
gegenüber der politik von russland unter
putin
weiter wird merken
[Applaus]
ja wir müssen europas souveränität
stärken das ist das motto unter dem die
frankreich emanuel manke seine
präsidentschaft gestellt hatte aber dann
müssen wir uns auch eigenständig bewegen
könnte es ist eine richtige überlegung
von mack ort zu sagen lasst uns
initiativen ergreifen dass dieses europa
nicht mehr von kurz und
mittelstreckenraketen
nuklearen charakters bedrohtes darüber
müssen wir in verhandlungen treten
und das ist europäische eigenständigkeit
und ich kann überhaupt nichts schlimmes
daran erkennen werter kollege warnte
pool wenn deutschland gerade in diesem
bemühen um nukleare abrüstung als
zweites mitgliedstaat der nato neben
norwegen da kommt übrigens der
nato-generalsekretär her mitglied
mitglied des atomwaffen verbots
vertrages mit beobachterstatus hat und
es würden sie werden erleben dass diese
koalition genau das oft in sicht und ich
wäre an ihrer stelle sehr sehr
vorsichtig an der frage china die
ministerin zu kritisieren sie sehen für
eine kanzlerin verantwortlich die 16
jahre sonderweg deutschlands gegenüber
china zu verantworten hat wo immer und
regelmäßig die frage der
wirtschaftsinteressen anders gewichtet
worden es ist als die werte und wie wir
mit dieser frage mit der neuen regierung
umgehen das können sie an einem kleinen
beispiel sehen als hätte keiner
erklärt hat er gebe einen schießbefehl
auf demonstranten und andere da was
diese bundesregierung die umgehend jede
form von rüstungsexporten abgestellt hat
sie haben jahrelang jahre lang an saudi
arabien an die täter des jemen krieges
und zuletzt auf den letzten drücker
ägypten waffen geliefert das ist eben
der unterschied und deswegen wollen wir
beim rüstungsexport von folge setzt in
diesem lande durchsetzen letzte
bemerkung ja
gute europäer wird man nicht dadurch
dass man immer in der mehrheit ist es
gehört zu einem guten europäer auch dass
man mal auch eine bittere niederlage
erleidet wie wir in der frage taxonomie
als bundesregierung es erlitten haben
das werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht
aufhalten können aber ich finde auf der
anderen seite auch wir sollten der
realität und sie sollten der realität
ins auge sehen das wird nichts daran
ändern beim klimaschutz wird niemand auf
atomkraft am ende setzen weil es zu
teuer ist im letzten jahr sind 250
gigawatt
erneuerbare kapazität weltweit ans netz
gegangen aber nur 0,5
0,5 nokia und das hat damit zu tun dass
die kilowattstunde strom aus
erneuerbaren energien für zwei bis drei
cent produziert werden kann werden sie
aus atomkraft für 20 bis 30 cent
produziert werden kann und das ist der
grund warum die bundesregierung sich
dafür einsetzen wird dass die g7 eine
klare initiative ergreifen zum ausbau
erneuerbarer energie in der welt und
übrigens auch in bayern
aufgrund der fortgeschrittenen zeit
bitte ich die rednerinnen und redner
auch auf ihre redezeit zu achten warum
bis jetzt sehr kulant aber ich bitte
dass wir auch in anbetracht auch der
zeit und was noch alles debatte auch vor
uns liegt heute darauf zu achten vielen
dank ich teile das wort der kollegin
kita fcs
präsident noch kurz anschließend nach
außen europa und menschenrechte gibt es
heute nämlich auch noch das ressort
umwelt und naturschutz was hier
frau außenministerin auch von meiner
stelle aus noch einmal allseits eine
glückliche hand für große aufgaben
kolleginnen und kollegen von klima bis
china wenn sie mir diese formulierung
erlauben von geldwertstabilität über
wirtschaftliche prosperität bis zu einer
gemeinsamen außen und sicherheitspolitik
nur gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern werden wir im globalen
wettbewerb bestehen
europa braucht ein starkes deutschland
aber um das zu sein brauchen wir als
größtes land ein funktionierendes europa
und ich glaube darüber sind sich hier im
haus die allermeisten zumindest einig
basis hierfür
bilden klarer regeln die achtung selbst
gegebenen rechts unser ziel muss es doch
sein dass vertrauen und damit die
akzeptanz der menschen in die handelnden
institutionen zu erhalten frau
ministerin sie haben das wort
regelbasiert genutzt mehrfach ich habe
mich darüber gefreut
wir werden sie daran messen dies ist im
übrigen untrennbar verbunden auch mit
dem handeln in unserem eigenen land nur
zwei beispiele wenn wir eine stärkung
gemeinsame außen und sicherheitspolitik
wollen dann müssen wir doch auch im
eigenen land bereit sein mittel zu
stellen und damit verantwortung zu
übernehmen das hat etwas mit der
stärkung auch der europäischen
souveränität zu tun sind sie wie wir
alle dazu bereit in der vergangenheit
war dies jedenfalls nicht immer der fall
und wenn wir geldwertstabilität herr
schmidt sie benannten den begriff
starker euro zurecht wollen und die
inflation vielen von uns zu recht
sorgenfalten aktuell auf die stirn
treiben dann muss uns doch auch der
weitere umgang mit themen wie dem
stabilitäts und wachstumspakt
beschäftigten sind sie sicher dass hier
in teilen der ampel in diesen tagen die
richtigen signale gesendet werden ich
erinnere daran erst vor kurzem haben
auch wir den weg frei gemacht hier in
diesem hause zu einem gemeinsam
wiederaufbau innerhalb der eu nach der
korona krise es wurden mittel in
historischer dimension zur verfügung
gestellt mit dabei ein paradigmenwechsel
die aufnahme von schulden durch die
europäische gemeinschaft die spielregeln
waren dabei glasklar wenn sie dabei
bleiben die damaligen bedingungen
einzuhalten auch in dieser koalition
dann haben sie uns an ihrer seite wenn
sie dir wird auch in diesen tagen
parallel eine diskussion beginnen die zu
einer neuregelung der aufweichung der
stabilitätskriterien im grundsatz
geradezu auffordern also in einer zeit
in welcher der beschriebene prozess
gerade erst seinen anfang genommen hat
dann endet diese diskussion die maximale
irritation und verunsicherung dann
müssen sie ebenso klar sagen wo sie
damit hinwollen kolleginnen und kollegen
es gibt keine guten schulden oder
schlechte schulden je nach politischen
schwerpunkte oder wetterlage die basis
für stabiles wachstum
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und damit verbunden
sozialer sicherheit liegt immer in einer
nachhaltigen finanzpolitik
ob in berlin oder in brüssel sie bildet
die grundlage für die einzelthemen die
es unstreitig zu benennen gilt und die
auch erwähnt wurden und am ende hat es
auch ganz viel mit
generationengerechtigkeit zu tun ein
weiteres thema sie wollen die
mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten des deutschen
bundestages am geschehen in europa
stärken hier haben sie uns an ihrer
seite
gleichzeitig liebäugeln sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag mit einem föderalen
bundesstaat europa kolleginnen und
kollegen dann müssen sie das klar
benennen an welchen weiteren stellen sie
nationale souveränität aufgeben wollen
oder besser gefragt wo lassen sie diese
souveränität bei anderen bad bereits
heute eigentlich nicht mehr zu das
beispiel wurde doch schon genannt der
entwurf der eu-kommission zur taxonomie
spricht dem nachhaltigkeitssiegel für
energieformen ich sage das jetzt ohne
bewertung aber lösen wir die großen
herausforderungen vor denen europa in
seiner vielfalt steht historisch in
teilen völlig unterschiedlich gewachsen
mit
nationalstaatlicher ideologie oder auch
also mal mit der macht des möglichen wie
ist bei diesem konkreten thema ihr
beitrag für einen zusammenhalt der
gemeinschaft und wie geht s weiter alles
über allem wir haben die frage zu
beantworten welche rolle muss dieser
kontinent in zukunft spielen um
wohlstand und sicherheit für seine
menschen in den mitgliedsstaaten auch
weiterhin zu gewährleisten in einer welt
die sich gerade neu sortiert in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag sehen wir viele
wohlfeile worte es wird umso spannender
sein zu sehen wie sie weiterhin konkret
mit leben erfüllen allein die
vergangenen tage jedenfalls lassen für
uns manche zweifel aufkommen wenn es um
die substanz geht wo es möglich ist
bieten wir zusammenarbeit an aber alles
andere werden wir kritisch hinterfragen
sie sagt patricia lips die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
für die cdu csu fraktion
ich erteile das wort axel schäfer spd
fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen ja liebe kollegin lips das ist
ein gutes angebot an zusammenarbeit und
ja sie können sicher sein dass dieser
bundeskanzler europa kann ebenso wie
willy brandt als außenminister ebenso
wie helmut schmidt als finanz- und
wirtschaftsminister konnte er in dieses
amt wo im europäischen rat schon gezeigt
hat was wir in europa bedeutet sie haben
ja zu recht auf den wiederaufbau von
hingewiesen olaf scholz kann europa und
deshalb können wir auch in dieser
koalition auch mit dieser
außenministerin europa voranbringen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und sagen wir das auch mal ganz klar
diese koalitionsvertrag ist das
integrations freundlichste dokument was
wir seit vielen vielen jahren in diesem
hause beschlossen haben weil es darauf
setzt dass wir als teil dieser
gemeinschaft in unserem ureigensten
interesse politik machen auf einem
kontinent der auch in zukunft prägend
sein soll und er sich in dieser welt
selbst behauptet und hier ist
angesprochen worden wo wir hin wollen
natürlich ist immer der weg auch das
ziel aber tatsächlich wollen wir in
richtung eines europäischen
bundesstaates
föderal und deshalb ist diese konferenz
zur zukunft europas so wichtig dass wir
da in diskussionen mit abgeordneten aus
anderen ländern aber vor allen dingen
auch mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern so
vorankommen dass auch klar ist nämlich
das wichtigste nationale interesse ist
nicht mehr die souveränität sondern das
wichtigste nationale interesse ist die
europäische einigung und was das und was
das in der praxis bedeutet als erstmals
hier für diesen reichstag eine wahl
anstand 1866 war im programm meiner
partei der satz dass man unter deutsche
einheit auch versteht zu einem
solidarischen europäischen staat
zukommen das wollen wir heute genauso
und stellen wir uns mal vor wenn wir
1866 auf diesen weg gegangen wären statt
der kriege und der weltkriege wo wir
heute in europa stünden und deshalb ist
das für uns so wichtig dass wir dieses
gemeinsame europa in diesem parlament
mit den fraktionen außer der afg
voranbringen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
europäisierung ist immer
demokratisierung und demokratisierung
ist vor allem parlamentarisierung die
spd steht dabei in einer besonderen
verpflichtung schon 1962 hat der
abgeordnete karl moment im bundestag den
gesetzentwurf eingebracht für die
direktwahl des europäischen parlaments
ist leider sind wir damals an cdu csu
und fdp noch gescheitert es hat 16 jahre
und zweier sozialdemokratischer kanzler
in europa bedarf dass wir das
durchgesetzt haben gott sei dank und
deshalb wird man der europapolitik auch
wichtig sein dass dieser deutsche
bundestag sich weiterhin auch als
partner auch als interessensvertreter
und partnerin des europäischen
parlamentes versteht nach dem prinzip
miteinander arbeiten und voneinander
lernen und das hat auch ganz praktische
konsequenzen für uns über die wir reden
sollten und dann bin ich wirklich
gespannt ob das über die koalition
hinaus auch breitere zustimmung findet
erstens wir brauchen eine bessere
öffentlichkeit dazu gehört
öffentlichkeit in ausschusssitzung wir
sollten im europaausschuss mit anfangen
wir haben hofreiter einen guten
vorsitzenden gewählt und wir sollten
damit auch deutlich machen dass das
insgesamt im bundestag dazu gehören
sollte also unfair dass nämlich
nicht öffentliche sitzung eben die
ausnahme sind und die regeln das
öffentliche ist sowie das im
europäischen parlament auch funktioniert
inklusive der anhörung die es da gibt
zum beispiel mit bank präsidenten
kommissaren und den
regierungsmitgliedern das machen wir ja
ohnehin und wir sollen an dieser stelle
auch stolz sein was schon mal in zeiten
gelungen ist damals auf initiative von
abgeordneten von fdp und spd dass
nämlich der dass nämlich der deutsche
kollege link dass nämlich der deutsche
bundestag als einziges parlament in
europas einziges nationales parlament
vor der investitur der kommission 2009
und 2014 den deutschen vorschlag für den
kommissar günther oettinger cdu angehört
hat in der öffentlichen debatte von der
dinge hat das übrigens gut gemacht und
wir damit gezeigt haben dass eben der
deutsche bundestag auch eine besondere
europapolitische verpflichtung hat und
das zweite was auch der mutige
entscheidungen ist das europäische
parlament ist vom
bundesverfassungsgericht in einer 5 zu
treiben mehrheit als minderwertiges
parlament bezeichnet worden ist dann
haben wir unter anderem dann
sperrklausel gegen übrigens die meinung
aller parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier hier die in straßburg die
in graz mit dabei waren sehen wir doch
offen sagen denn wir schreiben das in
unsere verfassung sei bei wahlen sind
sperrklausel bis maximal fünf prozent
möglichst wir kriegen das dann im
europäischen parlament auch hin plus
transnationalen listen wir haben es im
koalitionsvertrag stehen und ein dritter
punkt
lassen wir uns doch mal ganz ehrlich
sein
2014 wollen wir gut 2009 10 haben wir
versagt wir müssen bei der nächsten
europawahl garantieren dass die
spitzenkandidatin und spitzenkandidaten
hinterher auch tatsächlich wenn sie die
mehrheit haben kommissionspräsidenten
oder kommissionspräsidenten wert wenn
wir das so wie auch letzten mal machen
ist das genau so als hätte die cdu
mit armin laschet den wahlkampf geführt
als kanzlerkandidaten hinterher gesagt
eigentlich wollten wir lieber sondern
das geht beim nächsten mal bitte schön
nicht und ein letzter und ein letzter
punkt online letzter punkt auch das
gehört dazu es kann doch nicht sein dass
der bundestag allein und die vertreter
der länder den bundespräsidenten fell
und wir überhaupt nicht realisiert haben
dass zwischen 396 deutsche
europaabgeordnete wir haben vielleicht
zwei drei europaabgeordneten
bundespräsidenten wie kommen sie bitte
zum schluss noch ändern liebe
kolleginnen kollegen immer in einen
gemeinsamen geist der heißt das nicht
das wichtigste das nationale interesse
ist sondern dass wir als deutsche
gleichberechtigt die von siemens oder
opa dem frieden der welt bienen vielen
dank
ich erteile das wort nobert kleinwächter
auf die fraktion er wird von der tribüne
aus sprechen herr klein ich dass ich an
drei minuten redezeit wir geben ihnen
ein kurzes zeichen kurz bevor die
redezeit vorbei ist weil sie keine oben
sehen fehlende frau präsidentin wird es
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der friede der
welt kann nicht gewahrt werden ohne
schöpferische anstrengungen die der
größe der bedrohung entsprechen mit
diesen worten begann ganz bewusst robert
schumann der große visionär europas kann
man sagen der europäischen
zusammenarbeit 1950 seine berühmte
erklärung und ich darf gleich 1
vorausschicken schöpferische
anstrengungen kann man nun wirklich
nicht bescheinigen koalitionsvertrag
alles was sie gemacht haben waren die
ideen von emanuel makro zu kopieren und
meine damen und herren ich sage ihnen
ganz offen wenn ein präsident seine
eigenen bürger als nun sieht er als
nicht bürger bezeichnet weil sie einfach
nicht so spuren wie er sich das und
einbildet wenn er sagt er möchte sie mrd
disco bis zum ende aufreiben dann ist
dieser mann 1 0 präsident er ist kein
vorbild für europa sondern der es genau
die bedrohung für europa von der robert
schuman geschrieben hat und von der er
sprach und die wir auch verhindern müsse
nun eine hoffnung die ich an dieser
stelle wirklich ausdrücken darf das ist
dass die franzosen im april wenn sie
wählen dürfen diesem mann genauso wie
ihren völlig bizarren ideen einer reform
der europäischen union ein endgültiges
ende bereiten
denn das was sie wollen ist völlig
irrsinnig frau werbung sprach schon von
einer weltweiten sozialpolitik nadi mehr
leute merken doch schon dass es schlecht
geht mit inflation dass sie draufzahlen
dass sie ihr geld wert verlieren dass
sie oft ihre jobs verlieren es geht
schon in die falsche richtung und sie
wollen noch einen draufpacken mit einem
start eu
rechtssprechung des europäischen
gerichtshof grundsätzlich dem nationalen
recht vorgeht dann ist es völlig mumpitz
was wir hier beschließen wenn die eu was
sagt dann ist das gesetz wir wollen das
nicht
und sie wollen auch keine parlament sie
wollen funktionäre dorthin wählen lassen
überlisten die parteien irgendwie in
brüssel zusammen zimmern und dann können
die leute noch eine liste ankreuzen
realisten wahlen das kennen ja von
einheitsliste auf einem gewissen teil
deutschland brauche nicht wieder danke
haben wir gar
aber das schlimmste ist sie wollen kein
europa der menschen sie wollen da keine
europäische zusammenarbeit sie setzen
auf eine europäische union der
institutionen die hart durchgreifen und
harz durchregieren und deswegen denken
sie auch in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
immer nur an institutionen die bestrafen
wie der rechtsstaatlichkeit mechanismus
wenn irgendwo dann noch in der
europäischen union ein zartes pflänzchen
das souveränität oder das bewusstsein
über traditionen oder vielleicht auch
religion wächst was vielleicht nicht
ihren sehr engen vorstellungen
entspricht dann kommt die haube des
rechtsstaatlichkeit mechanismus und wird
diese zarte blume ausmerzen meine damen
und herren der langjährige begleiter von
robert schumann jean monnet schrieb
nichts ist möglich ohne die menschen
nichts ist dauerhaft ohne institutionen
und er meinte damit dass wir eine
europäische einigung eine europäische
verständigung vor allem die menschen
gebraucht werden jahn sekundär auf die
institutionen sie seien kleiner ihre
redezeit und schwache menschen wir
setzen auf starke menschen und
institutionen ja dies braucht die
funktionieren sollten aber so gering wie
möglich
norbert klein laster war dass wir all
die fraktionen nächster hier in der
aussprache zum bereich aus politik
europa menschenrechte ist bijan djir
sarai der außenpolitische sprecher der
fdp fraktion und jahr künftige
generalsekretär der fdp
meine damen und herren die
aussenpolitische debatte des heutigen
tages kommt zu einem richtigen zeitpunkt
bin sehr froh dass diese debatte heute
stattfindet noch hat uns die korona
pandemie sowohl in deutschland als auch
in ganz europa im griff es liegt daher
in der natur der sache dass wir zurzeit
besonders mit unseren eigenen problemen
und herausforderungen in erster linie
beschäftigt sind aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass die welt in der wir leben
sich dramatisch verändert und wir
sollten uns in deutschland und europa
mit diesen veränderungen intensiv
beschäftigen das was beispielsweise
china heute macht in asien im nahen und
mittleren osten in afrika hat
unmittelbar einfluss auf unsere
interessen in der welt die politischen
entwicklung ob in afghanistan syrien
oder libyen beeinflussen auch die in
politik in unserem land flucht
vertreibung und flucht
ursachenbekämpfung sind dabei zentrale
themen
unsere antwort auf die großen
veränderungen dieser welt kann aus
meiner sicht nur lauten mehr europa denn
europa das ist unsere zukunft und unsere
einzige möglichkeit auf die
herausforderungen der zeit einfluss zu
nehmen meine damen und herren
daher sollten wir alles dafür tun daher
sollten wir alles dafür tun damit wir
endlich eine gemeinsame und
handlungsfähige europäische außen- und
sicherheitspolitik schaffen können nicht
nur in der theorie für große reden
sondern auch in der praxis und ich will
es an dieser stelle auch deutlich sagen
ich finde es nicht gut wenn über die
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
gesprochen wird und europa nicht am
tisch sitzen man darf sich aber auch
nicht wundern denn schließlich hat sich
europa in den letzten jahren auch in der
außenpolitik unter wert verkauft und ein
gemacht und wer sich klein macht wird
auch dementsprechend behandelt
wir müssen in den nächsten jahren noch
stärker als zuvor unsere interessen in
der welt artikulieren und gleichzeitig
deutlich machen dass wir für unsere
werte stehen werte wie freiheit
demokratie
menschenrechte und bürgerrechte es heißt
deutsche außenpolitik soll
werteorientiert und interessengeleitet
sein noch nie war diese formulierung so
wichtig und so richtig denn es ist kein
oder es ist ein und und ich sehe keinen
widerspruch und ich sehe keinen
widerspruch zwischen einer
werteorientierten und
interessengeleiteten außenpolitik
allerdings dürfen wir einen fehler nicht
machen
wir dürfen eine werteorientierte
außenpolitik nicht mit einer
moralisierenden außenpolitik verwechselt
den fehler dürfen wir nicht machen wir
können nicht zu wir können dich zu
eklatanten menschenrechtsverletzungen in
china schweigen wir können nicht
schweigen wenn oppositionelle in
russland unterdrückt werden wir können
nicht schweigen wenn radikal
islamistische taliban in afghanistan mit
steinzeit methoden die menschen
tyrannisieren wir können nicht schweigen
wenn frauen im iran systematisch vom
regime diskriminiert und unterdrückt
werden wir müssen uns für diese menschen
einsetzen das sind wir denen schuldig
deren freiheit tagtäglich von diktatoren
und autokraten in frage gestellt wird
meine damen und herren meine damen und
herren diese bundesregierung hatte
außerordentlich schwierige
rahmenbedingungen bei ihrem start nicht
nur die korona pandemie sondern auch die
situation an der polnisch russischen
grenze und auch das verhalten russlands
an der ukrainische grenze waren vom
ersten tag an eine große herausforderung
frau ministerin frau ministerin berbalk
ich wünsche ihnen alles gute
erfolg das ist wichtig für uns das ist
wichtig für unser land sie sind erst
seit kurzem im amt aber die art und
weise wie sie dieses amt mit leben
gefüllt haben ist aus meiner sicht jetzt
schon überzeugt vielen dank
war das für die liberalen der
außenpolitische sprecher
und mutmaßlich künftige fdp
generalsekretär der nächste jahr am
rednerpult ist tomas andel er ist
mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss und
spricht hier für die cdu csu fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau ministerin ich wünsche ihnen eine
glückliche hand und bin gespannt wie sie
diese kohärente außenpolitik über
ministerkreis über ministeriums grenzen
hinweg umsetzen werden kohärente aus
politik das haben sie oft wiederholt in
ihrer rede und das ist gut dass wir
darüber reden weil bisher war nicht
wirklich klar ob diese bundesregierung
eine außenpolitik hat ich zweifel immer
noch daran denn bisher war ja in
zentralen fragen eher ein großes
durcheinander von einzelmeinungen zu
vernehmen ganz konkret sichtbar war es
bei 19
22 ministerin sie sind fleißig unterwegs
zeigen die großen themen auf
klimakrise international lösen blick auf
neue technologien sehr sehr wichtig
unterstützung von frauen
multilateralismus stärken
widerstandsfähigkeit der demokratien
erhöhen und den zusammenhalt europas
fördern das sind wichtige überschriften
ohne zweifel aber das ist noch keine
politik wir wollen wissen wie sie
konkret dahin kommen und wir leben
schließlich in einer würdigen traumwelt
sondern erfahren gerade in diesen tagen
dass wir mit knallharten machtfragen und
hybriden bedrohungen konfrontiert sind
und da ist heftigkeit da sind klare
positionen da es stärke und vor allem
eine einheitliche stimme unserer
regierung gefragt und keine koch und
kellner diskussion meine damen und
herren und wir müssen am tisch sitzen
wenn über unsere sicherheit verhandelt
wird
ich bin froh
dass der bundeskanzler in der
fragestunde vorhin seine große sorge
über die
russischen bewegungen über den
russischen aufmarsch an der ukrainischen
grenze zum ausdruck gebracht hat aber
insgesamt waren seine aussagen auch viel
zu unklar und vage es fehlt mir wirklich
eine vorstellung davon wie diese
bundesregierung konkret zur entspannung
mit russland beitragen will und
überhaupt muss die spd in russland
problem endlich in den griff kriegen
denn es geht nicht dass der
generalsekretär der größten
regierungspartei sagt das sei alles
nicht so tragisch in der ukraine wo man
sollte jetzt keinen konflikt der beiden
klammer auf wo keiner ist meint der
wahrscheinlich klammer zu und das ist
ein seltsamer informationsstand meine
damen und herren denn diese aussage
verhöhnt die vielen menschen die dem
konflikt im osten der ukraine in den
letzten jahren bereits zum opfer
gefallen sind ich meine kollegin hat
sollte diese aussage zurücknehmen und
sich bei den menschen in der ost ukraine
für diese entgleisung entschuldigen
außenpolitik hab mich für die ersten
gehversuche des neuen generalsekretärs
meine kolleginnen und kollegen und
verehrte frau ministerin ist
abschließend noch ein punkt wichtig
paris warschau washington rom das ist
alles sehr wichtig und richtig aber
bitte vergessen sie unsere kleineren
nachbarn nicht der zusammenhalt europas
funktioniert nur wenn alle mit dabei
sind jetzt im januar sind es 25 jahre
seit der unterzeichnung der deutsch
tschechischen erklärung ein so wichtiges
dokument mit dem diese schwierige
gemeinsame geschichte des letzten
jahrhunderts überwunden wurde und das
wäre ein guter anlass unseren kleineren
nachbarn zu zeigen ja wir sehen euch ja
ihr seid auch unsere partner auf
augenhöhe
meine damen und herren die neue
regierung ist jetzt einen monat im amt
es ist an der zeit dass sie geeint
deutschlands politisches und
wirtschaftliches gewicht einsetzt und
unsere übergeordneten ziele entschieden
verfolgt das in frieden freiheit
sicherheit und wohlstand in deutschland
und europa park sie es an dann sind wir
auch an jeder seite herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
zu ihrer ersten rede erteile ich das
wort der reaktor knapp bauer spd
fraktion
der erste frau präsidentin meine damen
meine herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
alle menschen sind frei und gleich an
würde und rechten geboren sie sind mit
vernunft und gewissen begabt und sollen
einander im geist der solidarität
begegnen so lautet der artikel 1 der
allgemeinen erklärung der menschenrechte
menschenrechte für die einen zum glück
so selbstverständlich dass sie in ihrem
alltag gar nicht sich damit
auseinandersetzen müssen für manche
andere vielleicht ein bisschen abstrakt
für eine zunehmende anzahl von menschen
hat allerdings der schutz ihrer
menschenrechte durchstarten wie
deutschland eine nicht zu
unterschätzende bedeutung
durch unseren einsatz zum schutz der
menschenrechte auf internationaler ebene
werden viele menschen erst die chancen
auf bürgerliche und politische freiheit
und soziale und kulturelle teilhabe
gewährt aus der bequemen perspektive
eines mitteleuropäischen staates ist es
vielleicht kaum vorstellbar dass
weltweit unter anderem das recht auf
leben das recht auf ein würdevolles
seien in freiheit oder das verbot von
folter eben nicht gelten oder eine
versammlungs und meinungsfreiheit nicht
garantiert ist ja ich spreche von der
wirklich rechtswidrigen unterdrückung
der meinungsfreiheit und nichts von dem
was sie angeblich rechts verteidigenden
sich der demokratie bedienenden aber
diktatur schreienden leer denker meinen
[Musik]
diese leute diese last präsentieren den
begriff der meinungsfreiheit und
begreifen nicht dass ihnen genau das
bewährt wird während die diktatur und
die jugendpresse schreien sogar eine
bundesministerin im hohen haus der
heuchlerei bezichtigen ohne dafür
konsequenzen befürchten zu müssen
viele können sich auch gar nicht
vorstellen dass es auch viel wohnraum
gruppen gibt aktien das sind etwa
frauen- mädchen- oder zugehörige der
lgbt
community die besonders die verletzung
ihrer menschenrechte leiden da sie
diesen oft fast schutzlos ausgesetzt
sind zum schutz der frauen und mädchen
werden wir uns für die verstärkte und
durchsetzung der istanbul konvention
einsetzen trotz der existierenden
regelungen und maßnahmen gegen die
schlecht bezogene gewalt besteht in
deutschland noch erheblicher
handlungsbedarf zur vollständigen
umsetzung der konvention und ich bin
sehr froh dass diese ampel koalition
fest entschlossen ist die erforderlichen
maßnahmen so schnell wie möglich
umzusetzen
neben der ratifizierung weitere
menschenrechtskonvention werden die
ebenso einer ratifizierung des
zusatzprotokolls zum sozialpakt der
vereinten nationen kümmern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von arbeit und
soziales hier ist jetzt auch ihr einsatz
gefragt ich glaube sie müssen dieses
jahr ein bisschen aktiv werden in dem
punkt apropos arbeit
arbeit darf nicht krank machen vor allem
aber dürfen menschen aufgrund ihrer
arbeit erst rechtlich verfolgt oder gar
getötet werden wenn die endstation bei
der ausübung des berufes zb im einsatz
für eine freie und unabhängige presse
das gefängnis ist liegt es in unserer
verantwortung die stimme zu erheben
einzuschreiten wenn aktivist innen sowie
menschenrechtsanwälte ihnen bedroht
verfolgt und eingesperrt werden deswegen
wollen wir uns verpflichten diese
menschen und ihre arbeit in ganz
besonderer weise zu stärken und sie auch
bei grenzüberschreitender verfolgung zu
schützen
das ist fast das umfasst auch die
gewährleistung einer unbürokratischen
aufnahme von hoch gefährdeten menschen
und die langfristige ausgestaltung
verschiedener förder und schutzprogramme
wir werden einen fonds zum ausgleich der
finanziellen schäden für im ausland
inhaftierte deutsche einrichten das ist
ein ganz wichtiger meilenstein der auf
unsere initiative hin im
koalitionsvertrag fest einzementiert
worden ist darüber bin ich sehr
glücklich
außerdem muss auf allen ebenen eine
ressortübergreifende koordination
konsequent umgesetzt werden dann nur so
eine effektive bekämpfung beispielsweise
des menschenhandels bekämpft werden kann
menschenrechtsverletzungen sind jedoch
nicht nur in den ländern statt über die
täglich in der presse zu lesen ist nein
sie finden auch in den staaten statt die
sich selbst als rechtsstaatlich
bezeichnen und mit denen wir auf
vielerlei ebenen partnerschaftlich auch
verbunden sind
menschenrechtsverletzung finden übrigens
auch hier in deutschland statt auch wenn
das hier im haus nicht unbedingt jeder
gerne hört und überall dort wo sie
begangen werden müssen sie aufgedeckt
und geahndet werden dazu gehört dann
auch
die im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart eine
bessere finanzielle und personelle
ausstattung von organisationen die etwa
des deutschen instituts für
menschenrechte oder der national stelle
zur verhütung von folter
darüber hinaus ist es nicht hinnehmbar
dass seine über staatliche institutionen
wie der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte recht spricht und dessen
urteile einfach im nichts verpufften
ohne dass die mitgliedsländer sich zu
deren umsetzung gezwungen sehen auch in
der zwischenstaatlichen zusammenarbeit
werden wir massiv darauf drängen und uns
politisch dafür stark machen dass diese
urteile ernst genommen und umgesetzt
werden und weiter zum thema recht die
straflosigkeit von
menschenrechtsverletzungen muss weltweit
beendet und die opfer müssen besser
geschützt werden besser engagieren wir
uns für die arbeit des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs der ad hoc tribunale
der vereinten nationen und werden uns
für eine weiterentwicklung des
humanitären völkerrechts einsetzen sie
sehen es gibt viel zu tun und sie hören
wir haben einen plan die alle hier ich
korrigiere leider nicht wir alle doch
die allermeisten von uns haben sich der
demokratie verschrieben und daher werden
wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass wie es
sich in einer demokratie gehört der
schutz der schwächsten auch bedeutet
dass in die gleichen chancen eingeräumt
werden wie den stärksten vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
maria türken die nach bauer war das für
die spd fraktion
wird sie künftig im ausschuss für
menschenrechte und humanitäre hilfe
sitzen und die menschenrechtspolitik
mehr zu fördern
daraufhin die unter anderem hier
brannten in fokus gelegt und
das ist auch so im koalitionsvertrag
verabredet michael brandt jetzt hier für
die cdu/csu-fraktion frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die neue
bundesregierung ist angetreten auch mit
dem anspruch unsere verfassungsmäßigen
grundwerte und die menschenrechte aktiv
zu vertreten national wie international
dazu wünschen wir ihnen liebe frau
ministerin werbung in der ganzen
bundesregierung nicht nur allen erfolg
sondern wir erwarten auch denn die
menschenrechte zählen zu unserer
staatsräson und in fragen der
staatsraison darf es keine faulen
kompromisse geben die bundesregierung
dafür übrigens auch nicht mit zwei
gesichtern reden das kann nicht sein
dass die außenministerin die
menschenrechte in den mittelpunkt stellt
und dass der bundeskanzler beim thema
china oder bei anderen themen offen oder
im hintergrund diese menschen
rechtsorientierte außenpolitik
einkassiert die bundesregierung darf
gerade in diesem feld nicht von beginn
an ihre glaubwürdigkeit verlieren
deutschland muss erkennbar bleiben und
die mitglieder der bundesregierung
dürfen nicht zu leeren gesichtern beim
thema menschenrechte werden die geltung
und die verteidigung der universellen
menschenrechte sind deshalb von so
strategischer bedeutung weil wir in
einer globalen auseinandersetzung um
nichts weniger als demokratie und
diktatur stehen seit vielen jahren haben
sowohl russland als auch china die
diktatur der oligarch und die diktatur
der partei gegen die menschen und ihre
rechte umgesetzt die menschen sind immer
weniger frei und nehme rechten immer
mehr unter druck und zudem exportieren
weitere länder ihr autoritäres und
aggressives konzept die entscheidende
politische auseinandersetzung unserer
zeit ist die und da haben sie recht die
zwischen liberaler demokratie und
autoritärer diktatur und wir haben es
mit nicht nur wirtschaftlich wichtigen
herausforderungen zu tun nämlich wir
haben es mit einem herausforderer zu tun
wie es ihn in der geschichte noch nie
gegeben hatte nämlich china und deshalb
ist es von strategischer bedeutung sich
mit china und der lage der
menschenrechte in china ernsthaft zu
befassen im inneren zeigt die brutale
unterdrückung der uiguren die von
internationalen völkerrechtlern sogar
als genozid bewertet wird den kern
dieses regimes es ist ein regime das
kein problem damit hat hunderte
millionen menschen zu unterdrücken und
über eine million menschen unter
brutalen bedingungen zu internieren die
nationalistische und diktatorische
regime in china ist die größte bedrohung
der liberalen weltordnung seit dem ende
der sowjetunion und wir müssen uns
dieser gefahr hier stellen bevor es zu
spät ist und deshalb liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ist es überhaupt nicht
unerheblich wie sich deutschland
gegenüber china verhält das konkrete
verhalten deutschlands wird entscheidend
zur verteidigung oder zur niederlage der
menschenrechte weltweit beitragen denn
wir sind lieber kollege schmid und da
darf man sich nicht hinter europa
verstecken man muss zur kenntnis nehmen
wir sind das politisch und
wirtschaftlich wichtigste land in der eu
dem noch immer größten wirtschaftsraum
die in china als absatzmarkt dringend
braucht
und wenn wir nur war menschenrechte
reden und sie zeitgleich verkaufen dann
werden wir diese globale
auseinandersetzung verlieren wer sich
mit china und dem regime befasst der
weiß dass die kommunistische führung
sehr aggressiv und sehr langfristig
denkt und agiert die schwächen des
westens sind dort sehr wohl
kant und auch seine unentschlossenheit
die er verachtet als verstanden wird wir
leben also nicht nur akut mit blick auf
russland die ukraine und anderen krisen
in schwieriger zeit schon heute
entscheiden wir maßgeblich über die
zukunft der freiheitlichen demokratie in
weltweit die neue bundesregierung
wünschen wir für diese wirklich
überragende aufgabe eine glückliche hand
den ankündigungen müssen dann auch
wirksame taten folgen und wir sollten
gemeinsam alles dafür tun dass
menschenrechte und demokratie am ende
dieser wahlperiode stärker dastehen und
nicht schwächer vielen dank
michael brandt war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der letzte redner tier
zum ressort aus in europa und
menschenrechte drei tage lang wird ja
hier die neue ampel bundesregierung ihre
pläne in allen politikfeldern
vorstellen jetzt hören wir aber nochmal
ivonne baki bundestagsvize präsidentin
frau möchte ich dem abgeordneten herrn
christian petri ein ordnungsruf
aussprechen
so das war noch ein nachtrag leider
konnte ich im moment nicht aufklären
diesen ordnungsruf wir versuchen es noch
einmal in erfahrung zu bringen